so many ladies have come to us and and
said that they've maybe they're on their
own but they are in some way feeling
like they need to be able to protect
themselves and they're considering
firearms some of them have gone out and
gotten their concealed carry permit but
find that they don't have the skills
necessary to feel confident to use a
firearm we have this ladies for liberty
camp where ladies can come in and we
teach fundamental safety and
marksmanship skills good safe firearms
handling for a good amount of time on
the range with the instructors when you
come to the Hillsdale ladies for a
Liberty program my main goal is for the
women to leave with confidence so many
women are nervous scared and you know
it's fear of the unknown coming into the
shooting sports and when they leave they
have such a confidence in themselves not
just for their firearm but if they can
learn things like this and 72 hours why
what else can they do you know if it
brings it to the next level when they
leave here
I really started at Ground Zero like
knowing nothing you know shaking holding
a gun to really really confident Lee
being able to shoot my big takeaway is
how empowering this is how great the
knowledge is to have a real education
about it the confidence coming to a
ladies for liberty camp is a great way
to be introduced to Hillsdale College we
have great professors that will talk on
different topics in the evening so you
get a good flavor of what Hillsdale
College is like for the students here
and the opportunities for adults and
other programs here the great part about
being here for this long and an event is
that you build great friendships with
the other ladies I come in and I'm
afraid and I'm quiet then you start
meeting all these wonderful women and
hearing their stories and they're so
welcoming and they cheer you on
and they just encourage you so much
everybody here's one I've ever
we want the ladies to feel welcome here
at our ladies for Liberty camp not just
as a firearms training opportunity but a
great way to come and make new
friendships and to have a fun experience
with the firearms you won't find a nicer
camp in the country for ladies
you